décidément 1973 aura été l'année d'un
virage dans les relations entre les
départements ou territoires d'outre-mer
et la france bernard stasi le ministre
de tutelle ira de ma visite est le plus
petit d'entre eux saint pierre et
miquelon
hier il a signé à paris un accord avec
les comores ce territoire accédera avant
cinq ans à l'indépendance
ces notables hull orientaux aujourd'hui
des français à part entière d'ici cinq
ans les citoyens de l'état indépendant
des comores tel sera l'effet d'un accord
que vient de discuter longuement à paris
une délégation gouvernementale de
l'archipel je crois que le comorien
conscients de leurs devoirs
conscient vers désirent ils n'ont jamais
voulu rompre avec la france c'est
pourquoi qu'ils ont demandé
l'indépendance dans l'amitié la
compréhension et la collaboration la
coopération à quatre ans les 300000
comoriens à la différence de leurs
voisins continentaux ou malgaches sont
en quasi-totalité musulmans si bien que
l'archipel compte près de 700 mosquées
[Musique]
mais si un haut-commissaire de france
réside à moroni la capitale
si les comoriens citoyens français comme
vous et moi élisent des députés et
sénateurs connaissent comme vous et moi
la peur du gendarme écoute comme vous et
moi des émissions de l'eau rtf
toutefois le régime d'autonomie interne
les avais déjà dotées de leur propre
chambre des députés et de leur
gouvernement
ces autorités locales verront leurs
pouvoirs accrus durant la période qui
précédera l'indépendance totale celle ci
prévue dans les cinq années à venir
résultera d'un référendum qu'il va
falloir organiser en tenant compte à la
fois du désir d'émancipation de la
majorité et du particularisme des quatre
îles constituant l'archipel à mayotte
en effet la plus riche et la plus
australe les élus ne sont pas d'accord
[Musique]
nous n'avons jamais eu à nous en
plaindre lors que l'autonomie interne
qui est qui date d'une quinzaine
d'années nous avons eu à subir des
répressions sanglantes on a connu des
répressions assez féroce de la part du
gouvernement comorien alors quand on
fait le parallèle entre les deux régimes
nous préférons de beaucoup dépendra
encore de la france
oui vos adversaires ceux qui sont au
gouvernement à l'heure actuelle affirme
au contraire que ces procédés sont venus
de vos partisans mais nous n'avons
encore tué personne de notre côté que
tant que je sache c'est visiblement
notre interlocuteur de mayotte que
dénonçait le président du gouvernement
partisan lui de l'indépendance dans
l'unité vent dire que mayotte est un cas
différent parmi les quatre îles de
l'archipel russie pour aussi puisque
mayotte composé en deux catégories les
catégories à qu'on appelle super
français et les catégories b qui reste
comme les autres il
comment définiriez-vous les super
français françaises que sont la preuve
qu'ils disent vive la france avec quatre
ports français tout amène à la gestapo
dans le deal massacre mettre du piment
dans les parties chéri de la femme
ouvert par les autorisant ces autorités
tout est protégé par et pour faire tout
menacer les gens préoccupe disent qu'ils
soient français par la force c'est
précisément dans l'espoir que d'ici là
les passions se seront apaisées et pour
ménager le temps du transfert des
services d'état au gouvernement local
que d'un commun accord une période de
transition a été acceptée avant
l'indépendance pour les habitants de
mayotte c'était aujourd'hui la deuxième
phase de leur choix après avoir dit oui
à la france
les habitants de la petite île ont voté
par référendum pour choisir leurs
statuts c'est-à-dire départements ou
territoires d'outre-mer notre envoyé
spécial bruno masure a suivi pour d'où
ce référendum dans le transall de
l'armée de l'air se pose sur la
minuscule piste daoudi on a un peu
l'impression de revenir cinq cents ans
en arrière
mayotte qui deviendra peut-être un jour
le centième départements français on
sera peut-être le plus beau mais il sans
conteste le plus pauvre
une grande partie des quarante mille
mahorais vivent dans la pauvreté pour ne
pas dire la misère mais apparemment tout
au moins heureux complètement ignorants
des pollutions de la vie moderne
ici pas de fumée du sinn pas
d'embouteillage ni de jukebox mais
pratiquement pas d'électricité ni d'eau
courante et encore surtout la lèpre ou
bien le choléra si cette île de 250
kilomètres carrés où 90% de la
population est analphabète musulmane est
polygame 6 at il tient tant à rester
française c'est surtout parce qu'elle
compte sur la france pour la défendre
des visées impérialistes des frères amis
comoriens
les élus voulaient la
départementalisation immédiate paris a
préféré proposer un statut spécial
pendant cinq ans d'ici là on espère
arriver à recoller les morceaux avec les
comoriens et surtout mettre mayotte sur
sa rampe de lancement économique tout en
effet tout reste à faire dans ce pays
qui importe presque tous y compris sa
nourriture aux grands profite d'ailleurs
de quelques-uns en attendant mayotte la
sauvage se met peu à peu à l'heure de la
métropole première conséquence du
oui franc et massif à la france les
jeunes mahorais feront désormais comme
tous les français un passage de 12 mois
à la caserne manifestement depuis de
nombreuses années l'attitude adoptée à
paris par tous les gouvernements était
de parler le moins souvent possible de
mayotte et de son avenir
cela ne voulait pas dire que dans les
cabinet des ministères concernés à
l'elysée on ne cherchait pas des
formules pour trouver une solution
équitable à cette question mais le
problème n'est pas simple depuis qu'il a
été posé en février 1976 lorsque les
mahorais se sont prononcés par un
référendum local pour leur rattachement
à la france
six mois auparavant le président mohamed
abd allah avait proclamé unilatéralement
l'indépendance des comores le statut de
collectivité territoriale accordé à
mayotte à cette époque est prorogée pour
cinq ans par l'assemblée nationale en
1979 vient donc à expiration à la fin de
cette année comment concilier d'une part
le désir maintes fois exprimée depuis
par les mahorais de rester français et
d'autre part les voeux émis
régulièrement par l'onu et
l'organisation de l'unité africaine de
replacer au plus vite
mayotte dans l'ensemble comorien la
république fédérale islamique des
comores fait pression d'ailleurs dans ce
sens actuellement le gouvernement
français agit en faveur d'un
rapprochement dans les domaines
économiques techniques et culturelles
entre mayotte et les comores mayotte
célébrer avec quelques semaines de
décalage la journée de la femme sur
cette île française des comores à
dominante musulmane
les femmes ne se cache pas le visage
avec un voile mais avec un masque de
beauté pour se protéger du soleil
entre tradition et émancipation mères
soeurs épouses naguère vigiles toujours
vigilante leurs couleurs château et
modestement au second plan d'une société
mahoraise endormi par 130 ans de
sécurité coloniale viril à mayotte les
femmes sont de tous les combats depuis
toujours chatouilleuse ou guérisseuse
masseuse ou sage-femme
elles ont veillé aujourd'hui elles sont
infirmières institutrice journalistes ou
bien chauffeur de taxi restauratrice
commerçantes ou chômeuse
à l'écouté de la réalité de l'île elle y
répondant l'actrice autonome du
développement local
l'émancipation de la femme fasse d'abord
par l'autonomie et l'autonomie ça veut
dire que la femme doit avoir un travail
ni indépendance financière
à mayotte les femmes ont acquis les
droit moderne que leur soeur d'europe et
d'amérique avec conquis mais les bois ni
de bambou est savent que c'est dans le
secret de leurs traditions qu'elles
puisent leur force leur identité leur
poids économique aussi en multipliant
les micro entreprises
elle tisse aujourd'hui la trame du tissu
économique de demain aux antilles les
décisions de jacques lang en faveur des
langues régionales à l'école était
attendu dans ces départements
le français coexiste avec le créole en
attente d'une pleine reconnaissance ce
dernier est déjà enseigné à mayotte en
revanche territoires français de l'océan
indien vers l'inde parler comme le
shimaoré ne sont pas autorisés en classe
dans cette île majoritairement non
francophones shimaoré demeure la langue
locale la plus utilisée au quotidien
mais désormais certains collèges incite
les élèves à utiliser le français au
sein de leur établissement
le français étant la langue de
l'intégration et de la réussite sociale
jetons indispensable que la règle du jeu
soit soit nettement défini c'est à dire
en classe pour des raisons d'efficacité
à ne serait-ce que parce que face à ce
que tout le monde scolaire comprennent
on parle français puis en plus c'est la
langue de leur avenir c'est là dedans et
qui vont pas céder
c'est dans cette langue qui vont passer
des examens en classe est obligé quand
par le français met dehors on a le droit
de parler man ray avec ses copines
conscients que leur avenir professionnel
en dépend pendant les cours les élèves
pratiquent donc avec assiduité de
français mais l'apprentissage de cette
langue est difficile et pendant les
récréations
les règlements sont oubliés le temps de
cet internet une solution à la pénurie
d'infirmières à mayotte le centre
hospitalier de mamoudzou compte sur le
nouveau personnel en cours de formation
dans une école créée sur place
l'hôpital doit répondre aux besoins en
soins d'une population de 140 mille
habitants exposés au choléra ou au
paludisme n'a d'yeux amati aime son
métier infirmière aux urgences pourtant
comme ses quelques 200 concerts du
centre hospitalier de mayotte
elle exerce dans des conditions très
difficiles ya carence ont une grande
carence d'infirmières dans le monde à
mayotte mayotte ne fait pas l'exception
donc c'est un métier
présumé déjà seulement voilà pour bien
soigner les patients il faut un
personnel suffisant et l'hôpital de
mamoudzou manque d'infirmières
le recrutement est difficile et 10% des
postes ne sont pas pourvus
heureusement l'année dernière le centre
hospitalier de mamoudzou a trouvé le
remède désormais des infirmières et des
infirmiers sont formés à mayotte dans le
cadre de l'institut de formation aux
soins infirmiers
ça va donner la possibilité de former
tous les ans des promotions de 15
étudiants donc affirmer l on entre à
l'institut de formation aux soins
infirmiers sur concours avec un niveau
baccalauréat ou 3 années d'expérience
validé dans le domaine sanitaire et
sociale la formation théorique et
pratique dure trois ans au bout un
diplôme d'état et la certitude de
trouver un emploi en attendant de
rejoindre l'union européenne et de
bénéficier pleinement de ces aides
mayotte se contente aujourd'hui des dons
octroyés par bruxelles des millions
d'euros dont des inspecteurs sont
chargés de suivre le bon usage
l'un d'entre eux vient d'arriver à
mamoudzou pour mayotte sur 5 ans et 10
millions d'euros qui seront donnés ici à
koungou paul chic un pas affecté cinq
cent mille euros à cette structure une
écloserie de poissons qui rendra
l'aquaculture mahoraise indépendante
si paul chicane vient bien à mayotte
pour donner des sommes énormes
pour le développement il vient aussi
contrôlé minutieusement l'utilisation
qui est faite de ces dons c'est un don
c'est pas des prêts cette donnée en
principe à mayotte
mayotte est pour nous est représentée
par les ordinateurs territoriales lors
de fêtes dans le moment paul chic un pas
visité mayotte aquaculture la seule
société de l'île exportatrices qui soit
complètement aux normes européennes une
société qui n'a bénéficié d'ailleurs
jusqu'à présent d'aucun soutien public
c'est l'union européenne qui va aussi
financer le futur centre d'enfouissement
des déchets et le réseau
d'assainissement de mamoudzou énorme
cela n'est rien à côté des sommes que
pourrait recevoir mayotte cl il faisait
partie intégrante de l'union européenne
comme la réunion
l'accès aux fonds structurels européens
des fonds destinés à mettre un
territoire au niveau moyen de l'europe
ces fonds bouleverserait complètement
l'avis de mayotte pour faire rentrer
lille dans le monde moderne bien ou mal
oui ou non réponse en 2010 et là ce
seront les mahorais qui décideront à
mayotte dans l'océan indien une
destruction aussi implacable que
symbolique du matériel de passeurs de
clandestins écrasé au bulldozer
deux jours après la découverte de seize
cordes anjouanais dans le lagon mayotte
montre sa détermination à lutter contre
l'immigration clandestine
le symbole est fort le message clair le
préfet assisté lui même à la destruction
de 16 kwassa kwassa ces embarcations
utilisées par les passeurs entre anjouan
et mayotte et 10 moteurs hors-bord
saisis par les autorités des médicaments
des cigarettes et d'autres produits de
contrebande ont aussi été broyés et
brûlé il s'agissait là de faire
appliquer la loi mais la dizaine de
corps sans vie de candidats à
l'émigration clandestine repêché dans
l'avion depuis le début de la semaine
donne une toute autre dimension à ces
taxes sont un drame humain c'est ce que
je dis depuis que je suis arrivé il ya
des gens qui en profite
et que
moi je ne peux que déplorer ce qui s'est
passé
et rendre hommage aux services de police
de gendarmerie de la douane de la marine
nationale qui se sont portés au secours
des malheureux dès qu'on a su que le
drame s'était noué mais c'est à dire
cinq heures après le début car en effet
ces vedettes rapides assure
frauduleusement la navette entre anjouan
et mayotte véritable eldorado mais
parfois elle mène à l'enfer
et c'est ainsi que le bras de mer qui
sépare maillot en juin et devenu
sûrement le plus grand cimetière de la
région les sanctions pourraient être
plus lourde pour les employeurs qui
recrutent des clandestins elles les
entreprises auraient notamment à leur
charge
le prix du billet retour de ses salariés
légaux un décret d'application est à
l'étude en france
c'est à mayotte que ce texte risque
d'avoir les plus fortes répercussions
lille est en effet gangréné par le
travail clandestin
les sans papiers qui viennent
principalement des comores représentent
déjà un tiers de la population amaury
guibert et philippe turpault ont suivi
sur place à un contrôle de l'inspection
du travail des chantiers comme celui ci
il y en a des dizaines sur l'eee pad
activités ici mais à mayotte
l'inspection du travail revient rarement
bredouille
par exemple un peu plus loin dans une
menuiserie des policiers partent en
courant dans la forêt pour rattraper les
ouvriers qui ont fui et cela le patron a
bien du mal à l'expliquer
ils sont partis les deux incendies je
sais pas peut-être qu'ils ont peur mais
n'importe quoi ce qui serait bien c'est
que vous changez de vous changer de
registre là on n'a jamais vu nulle part
quand les gens arrivent on des salariés
réguliers j'ai menti réguliers sont
allés l'un des employés finalement
repris un clandestin dont les papiers
malgaches ont été confisqués par le
patron un étranger parmi d'autres a tiré
par un eldorado
à mayotte le smic local est dix fois
plus élevé que le salaire moyen dans la
région mais les clandestins sont
rarement payé autant c'est une main
d'oeuvre bon marché très largement
exploité nouvel exemple avec ce garage
il y à un employé il dit avoir 17 ans et
être apprendre les uns des puciers là et
dans killer il est en situation
irrégulière j'ai pas de papiers sur site
et légumières d'accord celui voire dix
minutes plus tard le patron arrive pour
s'explique salariés
est ce que vous étiez au courant qu'il
était en situation irrégulière il n'a
pas dit vous n'êtes pas renseigné parce
que ici on savait pas que des comoriens
en situation irrégulière ou quoi combien
voulez payer par mois vous le savez die
connais rien c'est justement pour
l'aider sans savon comme ça on va se
situer soutenir dormir on va lui faire
reverser sur salaire parce que
vieira au sida
et l'inspection pourrait se poursuivre
encore longtemps tant le problème du
travail clandestin paraît insoluble à
mayotte un tiers de la population est en
situation irrégulière sans doute plus de
50% d'ici moins de 10
un mois après sa création la mission
d'information sur l'immigration à
mayotte commence dans l'île française
des comores françois baroin le ministre
de l'outre-mer l'avait annoncé après la
crise qu'avait provoqué localement sa
déclaration sur l'éventuelle remise en
cause du droit du sol dans les dom tom
cette députée composent la mission
d'information de l'assemblée nationale 3
ump dont montsûrs kamardine un udf de
socialistes ont de rené dosière le
président et un député pour le groupe
communiste et républicain
pendant quatre jours les députés vont
rencontrer les élus les partis
politiques et les associations pour
recueillir les divers points de vue
dès leur arrivée une douzaine de femmes
du mouvement départementaliste mahorais
avait un message à faire passer
je tiens dira qu ils ont du temps les
grands comoriens qui pensent que mayotte
leur appartient nous n'en voulons pas
nous avons fait le choix de rester
français ils ont choisi l'indépendance
qu'il ne vienne pas nous embêter
à l'issue de leur mission les députés
s'exprimeront notamment sur
l'opportunité de modifier ou non le
droit du sol à mayotte pour lutter
contre l'immigration clandestine dans
l'océan indien mayotte le smic va faire
un bond et le 1er juillet + 9 %
d'augmentation
ce qu'il portera à 706 euros un petit
mieux pour les mahorais qui sont encore
bien loin du smic métropolitain
les syndicats avaient réclamé une hausse
de 28 % du smic le préfet a tranché ce
sera 9,1 pour cent d'augmentation
le salaire minimum à mayotte passera
donc de 647 euros à 706 euros brut
mensuel
une hausse qui ne satisfait personne le
patronat estime que la facture sera trop
lourde
beaucoup d'entreprises sont en
difficulté il y en a même qui qui ont
confirmé ces derniers temps vous voyez
tous les problèmes liés les problèmes
sociaux liés aux grèves successives
empêchent beaucoup d'entreprises de
travailler les salariés quant à eux ne
sont pas plus satisfaits
il juge la hausse insuffisante pour
compenser la cherté de la vie sur place
personne qui habite à kani kéli qui fait
l'aller-retour pour train pour venir
travailler à langnau qui doit payer 12
euros de taxi par jour et qui mangent
des brochettes de trois héros ça lui
fait 15 euros par jour et 15 euros par
jour ça fait trois cent trente et un ans
a fait la moitié de son salaire
mais partir après plus rien malgré cette
hausse le smig mahorais reste en effet
largement inférieur à celui de métropole
706 euros contre 1250 2 euros pour
l'hexagone
à propos de l'immigration clandestine un
département français est plus concerné
que tout autre on en parle rarement il
s'agit de l'île de mayotte à 300 km de
madagascar et à 70 kilomètres des
premières îles des comores il compte
deux cent mille habitants
les candidats au séjour affluent de
toute l'afrique on estime que 30 à 50%
de la population est constituée de
clandestins c'est le dossier de cette
édition il est signé de nos envoyés
spéciaux renaud bernard didier da
jour de marché à mayotte
et tout d'un coup une voiture banalisée
de la police aux frontières arrivent les
vendeurs à la sauvette des clandestins
sont pris au piège
sur mamoudzou on va dire il 30 à 50 % de
la population qui est dans destine donc
on a de fait énormément de gens dans sa
sont régulières depuis mayotte la
française les comores sont visibles à
l'oeil nu entre les deux territoires
huit heures de mer sur des embarcations
de fortune qu'on appelle des kwassas sur
cette barque les clandestins se sont
entassés à 36 ils ont été interceptés
durant la traversée par une vedette de
la gendarmerie des malheureux attirés
par la perspective d'un niveau de vie 10
fois plus élevé que chez eux
mais ma maison qui qui vu qui vous
voulez aussi un une honda fit font bien
mieux que le resteront pour souffler
comme ça la misère qui pousse les
africains vers ce petit bout de france
pour treize mille clandestins
interpellés chaque année 40 mille passe
au travers des mailles du filet depuis
la côte d'ivoire moussa a traversé toute
l'afrique 6000 km le voici le passage
vers mayotte est moins dangereux et
moins coûteux que s'il était parti aux
canaries ou en italie à l'espagne la
traversée compagnies dangereuses
le devenir à mayotte et c'est comme cela
qui est apparue la cité africaine de
mayotte un bidonville toléré par les
autorités
les communautés s'y regroupent par pays
d'origine et les clandestins et découvre
la face cachée de l'eldorado rêvée pour
trouver et paix et que je pourrai manger
pour et notre loyer c'est difficile ça
coûte combien de loyer y650 héros dans
ce champs de salades ou la police et
l'inspection du travail vient
d'intervenir
les ouvriers étaient payés 2 euros de
l'heure au noir par cet homme qui sourit
un patron manifestement sans état d'âme
d'accord vous travaillez en famille sauf
que ces masses autour de la famille il
ya d'autres gens qui travaillent on en a
vu une vingtaine s'envoler il y en a
deux ou trois qui sont là ça fait quand
même une belle petite entreprise
familiale
quand je vois des gens qui travaillent
70 heures par semaine payés 200 euros
par mois
il s'agit effectivement d'un esclavage
moderne non c'est pas des états pourquoi
de 29 il travaille pas ici ils viennent
chercher leurs marchandises non
mais la police les a trouvés au chant en
train de cultiver
[Musique]
les clients cultive les champs non
oussaïd pourtant même quand arrive le
jour de l'expulsion
les clandestins annoncent qu'ils feront
tout pour revenir à mayotte face à manon
les endroits où nous ferions nabakoba
environ 300 parce qu'il ya sa femme et
ses enfants haïtiens c'est à eux que
revient si je veux atteindre le soldat
cathy collart quand même dommage et
royal s'il allait coincer reviendra
demain matin chaque année maillot tu
portes d'entrée de la france dans
l'océan indien procède avec ce bateau à
la moitié des reconduites à la frontière
de tout le territoire national
mais qu'ils viennent des comores ou
d'afrique continentale les clandestins
sont souvent de retour à mayotte
quelques jours seulement après leur
expulsion on a rarement vu un référendum
avec de tels résultats le oui l'a
emporté à 95,2 % hier soir à mayotte
l'île va donc devenir le 101e
département français mais pas avant 2011
cela va impliquer pas mal de changements
dans un territoire où une majorité de la
population ne parlent pas notre langue
ou la polygamie est chose courante et la
justice rendue par des dignitaires
musulmans arnaud goûter on attendait une
victoire du oui
pas forcément un raz-de-marée à 95,2 %
mayotte île française depuis 34 ans
devient département et s'ancre un peu
plus dans la république
ce comptage le département vieille
revendication marque un virage applaudi
des deux mains mais l'évolution sera
progressive avec les minima sociaux
prévus en 2011 et surtout l'apparition
de nouveaux impôts mayotte espère
toucher des fonds européens et certains
électeurs les réclament déjà avec
détermination qu'il nous faut c'est des
milliards et des milliards d'euros pour
qu'enfin mayotte soit développé le
département modèle laïque interdit
toutes nouvelles unions polygames ainsi
que la justice musulmane
les clandestins représenteraient un
quart de la population
beaucoup redoutent que le nouveau statut
augmente un peu plus l'immigration
illégale
devenu incontrôlable
[Musique]